on va parler de ce qui se passe du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron et de l'Assemblée
nationale puisque se joue après
législative Emmanuel Macron et bien
Steve vous avez suivi ça Emmanuel Macron
consulte avec une question va-t-il
pouvoir gouverner j'ai essayé de suivre
alors comment Emmanuel Macron va t-il se
sortir de ce pétrin depuis hier il
consulte les chefs des partis politiques
l'objectif c'est d'essayer d'évaluer les
marges de manœuvre qu'il aura dans les
semaines dans les mois dans les années
qui viennent au Parlement on rappelle un
chiffre Oriane il manque 44 députés à la
coalition présidentielle pour obtenir
une majorité et mettre en oeuvre ses
réformes alors à tous Seigneur tout
honneurs le premier rendez-vous du jour
hier était fixé à 10h avec le chef du
parti qui serait le plus susceptible de
collaborer j'ai nommer Christian Jacob
LR plus
UD + divers droites c'est 64 députés le
rendez-vous est duré 1h Emmanuel Macron
lui a demandé quel était sa vision des
choses il a répondu qu'un accord de
gouvernement n'était pas à l'ordre du
jour à écouter
c'était un échange
ils ont cordiales mais franc est direct
j'ai redis au président que il n'était
pas question pour pour nous de rentrer
dans ce qui pourrait être considéré
comme trahison de nos électeurs donc
nous avons fait une campagne dans
l'opposition à sa majorité dans
l'opposition à son gouvernement nous
restons dans une position dans
l'opposition de manière déterminée
déterminer mes responsables jamais on ne
sera dans le blocage des institutions
oui un autre chef de partie de
gouvernement la partie socialiste et
socialiste c'est 26 députés dans la
nouvelle Assemblée est-ce que les
socialistes seraient prêts à voter
certains textes proposés par le
gouvernement écouté la réponse d'Olivier
fort
si par exemple sur les salaires il est
prêt à passer le SMIC à 1500 euros nous
sommes disponibles nous avons discuté
des différents points sur les questions
institutionnelles sur des questions
écologiques sur les questions salariales
sur le pouvoir d'achat pour essayer de
faire avancer le pays moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'il en retiendrai je ne sais pas ce
que Emmanuel Macron aurait on sait pas
non plus Emmanuel Macron en tout cas
poursuivi ses consultations avec l'un de
ses alliés François Bayrou le chef du
MoDem qui prône lui une forme d'union
nationale pour faire face aux
difficultés que traverse le pays et il y
en a un autre qui évoque cette idée
cette idée d'union nationale c'est le
communiste Fabien Roussel Fabien Roussel
et ses 12 députés il a été interrogé sur
ce point par Emmanuel Macron est-ce que
sur le principe au moins est-ce que ça
pourrait le faire écouter la réponse de
Fabien Roussel
nous on a déjà participé un gouvernement
d'union nationale en 45 avec le général
de Gaulle donc ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui nous choque de participer avec
d'autres à la reconstruction de la
France mais tout dépend du projet et je
lui ai dit il faut un projet i level
comme je dis au niveau un pas d'un petit
politique pas des petits chèques il faut
une grande politique d'investissement
avec des grandes réformes Marine Le Pen
a également été reçu par Emmanuel Macron
le rassemblement national c'est 89
députés dans la nouvelle Assemblée le RN
sera le principal groupe d'opposition
Emmanuel Macron alors que et bien ces
dernières heures certaines déclarations
ont laissé croire que sur certains
textes la macronie ne serait pas contre
le soutien de voix RN sur certains
textes Marine Le Pen elle a rappelé les
deux thèmes qu'elle Martel depuis la
campagne présidentielle pouvoir d'achat
immigration écoutez j'ai exprimé au
président des sujets de préoccupation
comment dire
urgent qui sont ceux que porteront les
députés du rassemblement national savoir
pouvoir d'achat que cette impression qui
monte j'ai évoqué le ma vie inquiétude
sur une immigration absolument
anarchique et déréguée dont il ne me
paraît pas que les mesures qui sont
actuellement mises en oeuvre permettent
précisément de la contrôler suite des
consultations aujourd'hui Édouard
Philippe va être reçue pour son parti
horizon Julien Bayou et réalisé au nom
des Verts pour les insoumis ce sera
Adrien c'est la députée Mathilde panos
ça ne sera donc pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui n'est plus député une page est en
train de se tourner chez les insomnies
merci beaucoup vous savez très bien
suivi finalement
on a l'impression il veut un peu quand
on entend toutes ces chefs de parties
alors que tout le monde est d'accord
pour avancer tout le monde est d'accord
pour discuter mais personne n'est
vraiment d'accord pour travailler
concrètement avec Emmanuel Macron
non mais ça va se décanter on va voir
moi ce que je retiens et j'en étais à
peu près certain c'est que personne ne
peut prendre la responsabilité d'un
blocage et personne ne veut être accusé
justement d'irresponsabilités devant le
peuple français alors on va voir je
pense que
on va voir si des je dirais des terrains
d'antanques sont possibles il va y avoir
une heure de vérité qui va sonner 7h de
vérité ça va être effectivement le
paquet social là qu'on attend de lutte
contre l'inflation qui normalement doit
être présenté à l'assemblée avant
enfin au Conseil des ministres la
semaine prochaine et puis après oui moi
juillet on va voir aussi le discours de
politique générale de la première
ministre si c'est encore elle est-ce que
ce discours de politique générale sera
suivi d'un vote de confiance ou pas
Michel Rocard si on était sorti sans
vote de confiance puisqu'il n'y a pas de
il y a pas de d'obligation donc on va
voir ce qui va se passer moi je crois
que si vous voulez le s'il y a explosion
si il y a
une crise pour le coup alors une crise
politique une vraie crise politique
c'est peut-être pas pour tout de suite
pour vous on n'est pas dans une crise
politique non parce que les institutions
il y a pas de crise institutionnelle moi
je vois pas de crise institutionnelle
pour le moment c'est certainement pas
une crise de régime et vous avez un
président de la République qui a été
réélu vous avez une majorité certes elle
est relative certes pour redevenir
absolu il faut
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que du
temps de Michel Rocard parce que en plus
vous n'avez pas le 49-3 et puis vous
avez beaucoup plus de distance par
rapport à la majorité c'était quelques
d'une dizaine de députés maintenant
c'est beaucoup plus Édouard Philippe
disait contrairement en 88 on avait un
parti cent triste qui discutait avec la
majorité relative aujourd'hui on a plus
ça oui bien sûr mais est-ce que je
dirais
je pense que la radicalité qui est dans
le discours ici ou là pourra peut-être
s'estomper à l'Assemblée nationale et
puis il faut pas se je parle sous
contrôle d'un professeur de droit public
mais il faut pas se leurrer qu'il y a
énormément de textes énormément de
textes qui sont adopter à la majorité
relative voilà qui sont absolument pas
qu'ils soient absolument pas adoptés
j'entends la majorité relative parce que
bien tout le monde n'est pas là tout le
temps et donc ça permet de faire passer
quelques textes ce qui va être un vrai
défi parce que la majorité a été
assembles assez absentéiste lors du
dernier quinquennat donc il va falloir
qu'elle mobilise bien ses troupes mais
je suis assez d'accord en réalité c'est
à dire que il faut bien comprendre que
alors est-ce qu'il y aura un accord de
coalition probablement non parce qu'en
fait ni LR ni le PS c'est à peu près les
deux parties pour être visés Nyon
intérêt ça voudrait dire assumer le
bilan d'Emmanuel Macron lorsqu'ils
enverront un candidat en 2027 donc on
n'ira pas dans un accord de coalition à
l'allemande c'est très peu probable en
revanche il faut se remettre un peu dans
le contexte de 1958 quand Michel Debré
écrit la Constitution de la Cinquième il
a comme vision les assemblées de la
quatrième et de la troisième et il est
persuadé que jamais il n'y aura de
majorité absolue pléthorique disciplinée
à l'Assemblée nationale donc notre
Constitution a été écrite pensée
construite pour gérer ce type de
situation donc qu'est-ce qui va se
passer vous allez avoir cette émotion de
censure pour voter une motion de censure
vous devez avoir 289 des députés qui
votent pour ça signifie que le RN la
Nupe et LR plus quelques députés
supplémentaires votent le même texte
qu'est-ce qui va se passer très
probablement la nuque va déposer une
motion de censure le RN va dire moi je
mélange pas mes voies avec celle des
mélenchonistes le RN va déposer une
motion de censure la nuit va dire
l'extrême droite etc on ne votera
pastèque chacun va voter sa propre
émotion et le gouvernement tombera pas
vous allez avoir le budget le budget
c'est ce qui permet en règle générale de
déterminer qui est dans l'opposition qui
est dans la majorité la réalité c'est
que là vous pouvez utiliser le 49 alinéa
3 donc si vraiment il y a pas de
majorité même relative il y aura quand
même cette possibilité budget sur le
vote de confiance
[Musique]
est-ce que la déclaration de politique
générale est obligatoire et deux est-ce
que le vote de confiance derrière est
obligatoire et là ça marche et là ça
marche comment ce ne sont pas les mêmes
règles que pour la notion de sens c'est
pas du tout les mêmes règles mais il
n'est en effet pas obligatoire et il
citer tout à l'heure Rocard on pourrait
dire bérégo wakresson également
c'est-à-dire que le vote de confiance
évidemment c'est piéger pour un
gouvernement minoritaire parce que se
mettre d'accord sur une motion de
censure pour l'opposition c'est très
compliqué en revanche pour un
gouvernement faire l'unanimité des
oppositions contre lui en fait c'est une
façon de dire ce serait une façon de
dire pour les abeilles borne mesdames
messieurs de LR mesdames messieurs
durant mesdames Messieurs les fi est-ce
que vous m'aimez beaucoup au point de me
faire confiance et de rentrer dans une
forme de majorité avec moi la réponse
sera évidemment non y compris sur les
bancs de LR et donc le gouvernement
tomberait donc il est assez peu probable
que il y ait une demande de confiance au
Parlement mais c'est pas nécessaire bien
sûr pas de débuter un quinquennat sans
vote de confiance encore une fois ça a
été fait lors des périodes de
gouvernement minoritaire entre 88 et 93
et là entre guillemets personne enfin
s'il y en aura probablement qui
monteront au créneau et Mélenchon
et pour le coup il est évident que ce
serait une faute politique majeure parce
que si jamais on devait avoir des
gouvernements qui s'amusent à faire ça à
chaque fois lors de ce quinquennat là on
dans une vraie crise de régime type 1877
quand vous avez un premier à un
président de la République qui nomme des
premiers ministres et un parlement qui
les renverse pou sur coup et donc là on
est fait ce serait problématique mais si
vous passez du vote de confiance si vous
pariez sur le fait que jamais
l'opposition se mettra d'accord sur une
notion de censure et que vous gouvernez
ensuite texte par texte en essayant de
construire des majorités en réalité
encore une fois la Constitution a été
armée pensée construite pour ça et donc
on peut y arriver trop risqué ce vote de
confiance d'autant que les 12 ministres
qui ont été élus dimanche ne pourront
pas voter le 5 juillet puisqu'on peut
pas être ministre et voté et leur
suppléant ne rentreront à l'assemblée
que le 19 juillet donc il va manquer 12
voix au peu de voix qu'à la
majorités
ils peuvent très bien fonctionner comme
ça c'est prévu par la Constitution il y
a pas de vote de confiance prévue
pendant la Constitution donc on peut
très bien s'en sortir comme ça c'est pas
le plus important moi je pense que le
plus important aujourd'hui et pour les
années à venir c'est de savoir si la
France va pouvoir adopter et faire la
réforme qui sont nécessaires qui
s'imposent surtout dans un paysage
économique qui va être sérieusement
bouleversée me semble-t-il avec
l'inflation avec la hausse des prix avec
des difficultés économiques qui
s'amoncelle à l'horizon et là il va
falloir que politiquement il y a des
réponses et il faut que ces réponses et
bien on arrive à les trouver c'est idéal
le sujet alors c'est là où on va voir
d'ailleurs les les discours qui vont
différer considérablement parce que vous
allez avoir un gouvernement et une
majorité qui va être prise en étau entre
un rassemblement national et
une extrême gauche une nupaisse qui vont
jouer la surenchère et qui vont toujours
demander plus et donc plus de dépenses
et puis de l'autre côté les républicains
qui vont dire
mais oui mais comment vous financez tout
ça donc ça va être un jeu à mon avis qui
va être permanent
[Musique]
sur le fait que pour certains c'est pas
possible de jouer des blocages y compris
pour le rassemblement national
d'ailleurs davantage que pour la nupesse
s'il a du Pesse reste unie ce qui ne
serait être certain c'est que pour
briguer 2017 et maintenant Madame Le Pen
est en confiance pour se dire qu'un jour
peut-être elle sera président de la
République ça c'est clair en 2027
et bien vous pouvez pas jouer avec les
allumettes c'est à dire faire tomber le
gouvernement comme ça et être le
responsable d'un chaos politique donc
c'est pour ça aussi que à mon avis les
uns et les autres ont intérêt à trouver
je dirais des on est sur le fil du
rasoir mais ont intérêt à trouver des
compromis et des d'où l'idée on va
écouter Edouard Philippe il y a un
ancien Premier ministre puisqu'il a pris
la parole il était sur BFM d'où l'idée
de cette grande coalition qu'il a lancé
lui dit il faut il faut le changer le
mode de gouvernance on va l'écouter
nous allons devoir me semble-t-il
constituer une coalition ou une grande
coalition avec des gens qui spontanément
n'ont pas envie de travailler ensemble
avec des gens qui se sont engagés sur
des programmes différents
avec des gens qui se sont critiqués mais
la conséquence logique me semble-t-il de
ce que disent les Français au moment de
l'élection législative c'est de dire
écoutez prenez les groupes qui peuvent
s'entendre constituer une majorité ça ne
sera ni le programme entier sur lequel
le camp du président de la République
s'est engagé ni évidemment le programme
entier de ceux qui n'ont pas la majorité
mais tout autre solution me paraît être
constitutif d'un déni de prise au
sérieux de ce qu'on dit les Français
en Italie va de
la gauche l'extrême gauche à peu près la
gauche de la fi aujourd'hui jusqu'à la
Liga donc jusqu'à l'extrême droite donc
ça existe d'ailleurs en Europe c'est
quand même très improbable allez
expliqua Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui va
falloir assumer le bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2027 à l'expliqué Laurent
Wauquiez ou à Marine Le Pen qui va avoir
le même bilan assumé c'est compliqué le
présidentialisme rend ça de toute façon
extrêmement compliquée en France un
point sur tout à l'heure les réformes
c'est à dire que quand même ça va être
très compliqué prenez par exemple
exemple au hasard la réforme des
retraites la réforme des retraites si
jamais vous faites la réforme des
retraites vous allez avoir besoin de
l'appui forcément de LR et d'horizon qui
sont sur une vision assez dure du texte
mais l'autre côté faut pas oublier que
dimanche mais il y a également
Renaissance et que vous avez beaucoup de
députés macronistes qui sont passés à un
cheveu et qui sont dans des circuits de
gauche et pour le député macroniste qui
vient de renaissance 2027 c'est loin et
ses proches en même temps c'est à dire
que dans 2027 il y a deux choix Emmanuel
Macron ne se représente pas donc soit il
est battu par définition soit il trouve
un nouveau cheval dans tous les cas ça
circule de centre gauche s'il assume la
retraite à 65 ans il va avoir du mal à
la garder donc on risque également et on
a eu des déperditions lors du dernier
quinquennat d'avoir des tensions au sein
même de la majorité c'est à dire que
cette majorité ensemble elle est déjà
très difficilement gouvernable si elle
avait une majoritaire absolue entre
horizons le modem et les députés
renaissance de la gauche et du centre
c'est vraiment des tensions qui sont
très très fortes donc aujourd'hui mener
une réforme sur ce sujet là c'est risqué
de perdre justement ces députés de
gauche par ailleurs il faut voir que
tous les phénomènes d'obstruction dans
l'histoire qui ont marché ont toujours
trois piliers vous avez d'un côté une
opposition qui a une culture
parlementaire et qui sait faire de
l'obstruction pouvait faire confiance à
la nuque là où vous avez des
spécialistes qui savent comment ça
marche vous avez des relais syndicaux
parce que l'obstruction de ça ne sert
qu'à une chose c'est faire monter la
mayonnaise dans la rue pour ensuite
fragiliser le gouvernement et vous avez
une majorité clivée une majorité dont
une partie peut jouer contre l'autre et
dont une partie dit on arrête parce que
là c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement qui
va tomber or là on a même pas de
majorité du tout donc de telles réformes
vont être lors de ce quinquennat
extrêmement extrêmement radioactive et
ça va aussi poser les radioactifs ça
m'aurait fait le sujet avec le nucléaire
la 35 le nucléaire mais j'ai d'abord une
question
dans une dernière question parce que
Benjamin il pose aussi la question des
perdu en même temps finalement et au
sein de la majorité et au-delà ce matin
j'ai relâché dans Le Parisien il dit
voilà les limites du en même temps 72
députés LFI 89 députés RN en clair ça a
amené les extrêmes à l'Assemblée oui
peut-être c'est possible mais genre à
l'archer est aussi responsable de cela
parce que à mon avis la situation et
l'éclatement du pays
si vous voulez la fragmentation à
l'Assemblée nationale reflète la société
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui la France
qui est complètement fracturée qui est
et à laquelle on n'a pas su répondre de
ces fractures on n'a pas su les combler
depuis des années et des années droite
et gauche confondues donc vous savez on
est on est dans la suite du dégagisme on
est dans la suite de tous les mouvements
de colère que les Français expriment
depuis des années et des années et à
laquelle et auquel les les le personnel
politique n'a pas su répondre
[Musique]